je pense que j'enregistre un peu là-dessus de
toute façon ou peut-être que oui, fais comme ça et
fais aussi une inclinaison vers le bas, ok, comme si tu étais sur
la neige, puis tu t'inclines vers
le nuage,
ok,
drôle, tu ne sais pas où nous sommes comme
ça  tu
t'arrêtes j'arrête juste d'enregistrer très bas
on devrait juste essayer le doubleur là-dessus
tu veux passer en 1D et et le
doubleur voir à quoi ressemble l'image
c'est plutôt sympa ça ne bouge pas
donc c'est plutôt cool he Co ouais il est  il ne
fait rien il ne bouge juste pas et
nous regarde ouais attends viens c'est un très
beau cliché tu vois les
traces le camion parfait dis moi si ce que
tu penses de la
mise au point
ce n'est pas
génial il n'a pas l'air effrayé et si on
arrête on
tu vois  ici à
droite à 2h00, position 2
3h00 oh
ouais, il est juste là, assis
là, en fait, pouvons-nous, euh, peut-être juste essayer
de voler plus près, descendez pour que nous voyions que
euh, revenez à une fois, une fois, revenez
à l'autre roue à filtres  peu importe, c'était
plutôt sympa, une autre
pile SE ouais ouais ouais c'est mieux ouais
ouvre-toi là-dessus ouais c'est mieux si on
descend plus bas, nous verrons l'eau derrière
eux ouais c'est cool et puis commence en
quelque sorte
non c'est un peu  un peu sous-exposé, je
pense qu'il
y a de l'eau
[Musique]
maintenant, il
n'a pas peur du tout en fait ouais,
essayez juste de vous rapprocher un peu plus pour
voir ce qui se passe et essayez de ne pas mettre de
glace, mettez juste euh pas de neige sur le
dos  juste de l'eau de neige et c'est
tout comme ça comme ça comme ça ouais
pas jusqu'au bas ouais
ouais ouais c'est
mieux sinon tu ne comprends pas
d'où vient le vent
Super
ok je commence à me laver le duvet
ouais ok garde garde un  un peu de
vitesse pour ne pas avoir de descente
sur la
vitesse L
[Musique]
vitesse,
non, je suis un vent arrière maintenant, ok,
ok, il se lève ouais mais il ne
bouge toujours pas non, il n'a toujours pas bougé  il n'a pas
encore bougé, il se retourne juste et
lance en quelque sorte le carburant J qu'il renifle
ouais o c'est vraiment bien tu obtiens o
parfait Concentre-toi, ils se
concentrent, tu es avec le D non non tu n'es
pas encore
oh il boit non je ne le fais pas  je sais ce qu'il
fait, probablement même en
allant wow
wow
euh, pouvons-nous réessayer le double, nous essayons le
double, d'accord si tu veux, ouais, d'accord, je ne suis pas
sûr que ça va fonctionner, mais nous allons
essayer, c'est bien de
bouger, euh
vitesse va est-ce qu'il va à l'eau non il
marche en fait assez lentement courir
ok revenir à une
fois il court ouais ok ok est-ce qu'il
va à l'eau ou à
la terre euh c'est s'il se dirige vers
l'eau nous le mettrons dans le  l'eau non,
il va à l'eau en fait
ouais ils se sont arrêtés, ils se sont
arrêtés et pouvez-vous D Zoomer comme zoomer
puis
sortir peut-être faire cette photo mais où quand on
voit le siège le dossier
ok laisse le cercle autour et nous nous BL
la neige
ouais oh
oui on le voit très
bien on peut voir son empreinte ouais peut-être
essayer de se rapprocher
à nouveau je veux euh quand nous serons très proches
j'essaierai à nouveau le dou ok ok on se rapproche
maintenant
ouais
coupe devant lui je ne  Je ne sais pas
où nous allons,
il ne s'éloigne pas de l'eau,
n'est-ce pas ouais, il marche juste, c'est
drôle qu'il aille maintenant oh c'est
génial oh
F ne bouge pas, ne
bouge pas,
ok,
ok et puis peut-être réessayer  une
fois ouais peut-être essayer de faire ça euh zoom arrière
avec le c dans le dos ok il est de
ton
côté je ne peux pas le voir pour le moment
ok ok s'il a l'eau ce serait
bien ce serait bien si nous pouvions d'où vient
fais un
virage à droite, j'ai un peu d'échappement, maintenant
ce grand angle comme ça là où il est,
ouais tu l'as ouais, je
l'aurai dans une seconde quand je zoomerai, je
ne peux pas le voir en grand angle mais j'y
arriverai  ça
je peux le voir c'est à gauche à
gauche à
gauche c'est juste ouais au milieu de
ton
image à ta gauche c'est un peu de
neige Tout droit tout droit tout droit ça
va bien juste à côté de ce petit doigt
de glace ok j'ai
si
vous faites le tour de la terre, l'
autre côté les rapproche de
l'eau, c'est intéressant et si vous faites
Zoom, avez-vous toujours l'eau non je non
je ne pense pas que je le ferai mais je le ferai,
c'est comme un vrai  animal mature ce n'est
pas comme un bébé qui court partout
ouais pas du tout SC ouais oh
désolé niveau
ok peut-être à
refaire où sommes-nous au soleil pour
voir ok
pouvons-nous juste nous rapprocher un peu de ça, c'est parti
ok  on dirait qu'il se rapproche de
l'eau, essayons à nouveau le dber,
allons à la roue à filtres numéro deux et
arrêtons-nous un peu
plus,
rapprochons-nous un peu,
c'est sympa avec une ombre, pouvons-nous faire
le tour devant pour l'obtenir ainsi  l'
eau est derrière
ouais
et fais un zoom arrière oh je ne peux pas vraiment le faire
avec un Dun euh
je vais essayer ça pourrait en quelque sorte perdre la
concentration je vais lui donner
un non ça ne va pas
marcher on dirait que ça arrive vers  nous
ouais
il est en colère il veut te frapper il
revient sur ses traces n'est-ce pas ou il ouais
on dirait que
ne semble pas vraiment
réagir il a beaucoup à nous mais alors c'est
difficile de
savoir
peut-être que
nous vraiment  près de lui
avec son retour à la base d'origine est-ce qu'on
dirait qu'il va juste
s'asseoir à nouveau va s'asseoir ouais c'est
drôle fait son exercice pour la
journée là-bas on y
va bien il est désolé B
zy probablement en train de boire ou
quelque chose comme ça, peux-tu  juste un peu,
essaie de t'en rapprocher encore plus euh je ne sais pas non non c'est
plus proche c'est une très belle
photo qu'en est-il du zoom non ok je
vais juste revenir à une fois
et ensuite je dézoomer ouais faire un zoom arrière
peut-être que le niveau de chose à droite, laisse-moi faire la
même chose avec le niveau de niveau, ok, je suis au
niveau, bon
sang, est-ce
là juste un peu, vole juste un peu vers la gauche,
un peu de
mouvement, il nous regarde,
je me déplace vers la droite.  ouais ok et
peut-être faire le tour de l'autre côté pour que ce soit
rétro-éclairé parce que pour le moment tu ne
veux pas que nous ayons euh nous derrière lui ouais
ouais ok continue juste à droite euh
continue à faire un grand cercle de la main gauche continue
à faire un cercle autour  lui avec
la caméra à droite et pour qu'il soit,
nous regardons vers le sud et
sommes un peu plus en arrière pour le moment,
c'est vraiment difficile à voir sur la
prise de vue à grand angle car c'est juste un
léger changement de couleur  sur la
neige alors que si on dans l'autre sens on
voyait un peu de silhouette un
peu d'Ombre
aussi je devrais
changer de cassettes ce
Co
ce cool je dois vérifier